you know after a wash when you take your
socks yeah you put that in your mouth
yeah it's literally the same taste
amazing no no no no
incredible bonjour bonjour
yes how's it going yeah not bad not bad
sorry for my
you're french i'm french yeah you're
born in france you're gonna be bringing
some good snacks to the table today
yeah yeah yeah and we know the winner
before you when we start so
we'll say let's see let's try and get
off from the right foot
[Laughter]
bang this is what we're talking about
wow you know i've been like literally
craving for that
that looks scary vinnie that's just that
that looks like my wife
should we go with your first yeah
would you mind can i just introduce you
to the incredibly stupid little baby
ghost
here we go look at the look at the
thinness of it
that's vintage paper
i feel like
the flavour is there but it says it's a
monster munch
yeah it's not a monster and what is this
word gout main other than
scout no good peace
taste barbecue okay eat enough of them
you don't want to get gout on the
barbecue
you're loving it isn't it not
particularly vinny
not doing it for me all right okay let's
move to your family
let's go over this come on you do it
together here convenient
this has started off quite aggressive
yeah absolutely let's be friends
we'll be friends let's be friends come
on
okay right vinnie let's just break this
down together okay look look at the
size difference look at this you've got
crunch
you've got more texture is that meant to
be a monster
the flyer is scary they're two different
uh kind of crisp okay we have to agree
with that
get off the fence really okay more
texture more complexity more crunchy
this is literally melting in my mouth
the size of the pack is bigger and i
kind of find the barbecue taste in it
we're not gonna agree on that
this is the one okay i'm going british
walkers monster munch for me they've got
all bases covered
this was a decent crisp but i think the
name lets it down well monster mode it's
not nothing monstrous about it is it
about the goal
the guard you see one two three
away boom on toast boom okay
i don't mind
should we do the french one come on
let's go yeah i'm excited
there's no cheese on toast but sure what
flavor is good
the baguette that's some british bacon
that's not french burger
it's time to get no technical do you see
the mixture radiant butter
the flavor did you see that that is a
wonderful dish you've got the
the fresh sharpness of the radish some
intense flavor yeah creamy butter
and you know what i feel beautiful empty
when i do yeah even though there's
butter in it
i feel like we both feel healthy we want
to look healthy
but we feel it yeah now the british
option
beans on toast yeah vinnie on behalf of
myself from the british club public keep
your chins up
okay this is the one this is the
heartbeat of britain
toast looks good i just don't know how
you can compete with this vinnie
the bean companies heinz you bleep that
out they are renowned for coming after
people that badmouth them on
on social media so children you know
i'll give it to you
yeah beans on toast because this is
famous
i need to come out and you know i might
have to face all your community after
i don't want to be in trouble with
anyone beans on toast guys
well done thank you for your honesty
yeah and i have to be honest
yes boom we've won
german crumpets what is that crepe crap
chocolate crepe vinnies just let you
know the queen would have trumpets
yeah i'm not the queen i can't imagine
queen would have
might look like the queen but i'm not
doing that this looks something you put
in a pack lunch for the kids
this is what you eat in the morning with
a cup of tea a nice cup of coffee
okay lad bible see what your crumb it's
like
oh that's a good crumb i'm the feeling
i'm eating a spongebob
it's spongy it's got butter on it and
it's got some pretty decent jam
we've got stuff going on here i actually
think i actually think that bubble has
stitched you up a little bitty by
putting such an inferior product up
against the
british crumpet you can grab that for
snacks it's dry
that's right you know what i've bought a
lot of the fresh ones if you have the
fresh one
it's like this pancake oh i actually
feel sorry if you've been here you can't
but you can't compete with this i'm
literally giving you to read to you the
crumpet for me has got more going on
in fact i want some more there's a
little cranberry that bubble
here we go oh okay
okay agree nonsense
i'm not gonna lie to you mad i never had
absent before okay
okay but i know for a fact this is some
proper stuff
okay i've had it a few times so we might
just ah you added before normally after
about
35 pints so okay
cheers all right here we go
this is a smaller meaty or spam you know
that
small flavor in there yeah next to no
flavor
for something which is like slight
warmth going on you know for six years
personal tour i would be struggling to
doing that
i can't literally finish later yeah come
on
you might as well come on come on are
you driving and i'm just like trying to
out like i'm
yeah but yeah to get vinnie drunk and
he'll be uh you know a little swaying
now we're onto the old speckled hen yeah
so what's that
it's a it's an it's an english ale i
prefer lager
um yeah but look the flavor will
definitely be there
amazing no no no no incredible it's
literally you know after a wash when you
take your socks
yeah you put that in your mouth yeah
it's literally the same
clear winner for me old speckled hen up
the british
before you know what i'll give it to you
yes he's conceived
i'll give you two absolutely up here for
thinking down here for dancing there we
[Laughter]
go
i know what that is that's it i think
we're gonna be struggling with this one
in england
no no no no no let's start with yours
yeah i want to have a better taste
after so you know what let's start with
yours let's have a quick look it's got
bits in there
here we go let's be honest
come on it's incredible yeah okay yeah
this is the best i feel a bit stitched
down there with bread and nice bread and
butter
just bread and baguette you take some
baggage butter take it
enough so the french one for this one
right
oh god bang bang this is what i'm
talking about my friend
now they're giving us the school snacks
okay yeah
okay should we start with yours yeah
come on let's do it so the idea is
vinnie you've got ham cheese and biscuit
and you can build your own it's not the
most elegant of food yeah vinny
i'm gonna admit it but i'm gonna adjust
the taste mainly okay you you dive in
it's very plain it's plain isn't it
it's plain personally
there's not a lot of flavour going on
the cheese is plasticky
especially to a man a french man cheese
in france
is exceptional i actually thought this
is a bit of an insult uh to my my lovely
colleague
you need to pick your battles people
okay so do we just unpeel it
yeah vinnie yeah oh look at that look
quite a delicate little unpeeling
process
oh wow this is really fun already and
you know what's the funny thing
they put jokes in there there's jokes
and then how many people check
those koalas sleeps 20 hours a day is it
a stipend or a question it's a question
does the koala sleep 20 hours a day yes
yes
hilarious yeah you learn you you educate
yourself while you eat
ah instead of stacking biscuits
okay listen just have it come on you
know what you want some flavor now yeah
okay you want some flavor
[Music]
it's good it's good though now don't
be nice if you spread that is good
yeah literally where we won i think for
that no for that
how to make them both better we should
have one point each would you agree no
no no no no no no no no
i'm not giving you that way for like
some legos or i don't know what it is no
fair fair point a clear winner for me
okay cool i tried people i tried
yes get in there sorry vinny
we won we won you know
he's into that literally we've won thank
you
it's a pleasure merci beaucoup with my
honor to sit here on the
last bubble table for snack wars
my friend vinnie here is going to have a
shot um
yeah that is for you
but we all know there was real winner is
france
bang bang
oh mate i don't even need to try these
oh my god
oh it's been so long ah
there holy yo
yeah i'm taking leaves from